indeed it was for us a very
important historical moment first of all
to make sure that
the european union stands firmly at the
side
of india in this most challenging time
and we assure the prime minister of our
solidarity
and the support um with all what is
needed at the moment being from
ex-oxygen generators
to medicines and ventilators
it was a remarkable summit because
it widened the scope and the view
on the untapped potential in the
relationship of the european union
and india and we have agreed that we
will resume
the negotiations on a free trade
agreement
we will also launch negotiations on
investment
production protection and of
negotiations on the important topic of
geographical
indications we also discussed the topic
of climate change
india is the fourth biggest emitter of
greenhouse gases in the world
and it is impressive to see
how india is stepping forward now in
this topic
too we discussed the
importance of committing to climate
neutrality
and complete phase out from fossil fuels
for example in view of the crucial
un cop 26 6 and last but not least
our partnership on connectivity it is
the second
only of such a connectivity partnership
after japan it will bring our two
regions closer
in mobility and transport but of course
also
in the digital field india is a
powerhouse of digitization
so this shows the width and these were
only a few examples
of the cooperation with india thanks
again to antonio costa for having
convened this summit
thank you